[Music]
welcome to earbiscus the podcast where
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time I'm Rhett and I'm link this
week at the round table of dim lighting
we got some catching up to do Rhett
we haven't talked about our breaks and
here we are slam bam thank you ma'am
right in the middle of 2023 in January
well you know it's not in the middle of
the Year we're in the middle of the
start of the year so like
is that interesting to you well what I
was going to say was
we typically are able to really
successfully hide from one another the
things that we're going to talk about on
your biscuits but
there's some circumstantial factors that
have played into the fact that I feel
like I've already told you a few of the
things that I'm going to tell you again
because oh I was hung out with friends
if there's not if it's not Mike's
rolling okay I don't listen to you I saw
that you had a far away look in your
eyes I just thought it was your new
glasses upstairs still adjusting to them
how are you processing the feedback
because it's one of those things where I
don't give a [ __ ] uh it's one of those
things where I did talk to Christy you
made this Choice like you know in our
world you made this Choice like a month
or more ago six two months ago right to
to I bought the glasses and I started
wearing them in especially in my own
time and on non-screen time but I try to
avoid you know I don't like to
completely disengage from comments and
and you know because I just feel like
that's too too disengaged from what
people are saying but I try to just dip
in a little bit and then it's just of
course because yeah I didn't record it
we're recording this after there's only
a few episodes of GMM out for the year
and
people have opinions about your glasses
oh of course they do I love that they
have opinions and I do give a little bit
of a [ __ ] let's be real
I give I've given it's like
you know the when you like when it's
rabbit turds
you know you can almost eat those
what
because they love cereal
I'm saying if I had you know what I'll
save them next time if I had to eat a
turd the rabbit would be probably the
first yeah but I'm talking about my
turds that just happened I don't want to
eat your turds I have drank your piss
before when I'm talking about rabbit
turds I'm talking about through a filter
my
turns your turds okay keep going with
this analogy that I don't understand yet
I it's it's a little [ __ ] oh you give a
little [ __ ] I give a little rabbit turd
about what people think about my glasses
um but I'm determined to stick to my
guns which is I liked these glasses I
like them too I think you should I first
of all when I have the Gray beard I can
wear these glasses the gray ones or the
clear ones but like when I don't have
the beard I really like the brown ones
so I actually have the beard just so I
can wear these glasses
what happens if you wear the glasses
with the beard I don't think it the
other one
what happens if you have dark glasses
with those that's fine that's fine but
you can't wear those without a beard
that's what I feel like
why I don't know it's just something
about the look of it
that I you know that I that's how I
think about it but yeah I I know that
people are talking about the glasses and
that's great it gives the people
something to talk about because they
want something to talk about something
to Bonnie rate
um
I'm two for two man give me some more
song song lyrics uh so yeah we're gonna
we're gonna get into the stuff that
maybe you've already told me a little
bit about I'll I'll get into it I'll
tell you better I'll tell you better
last time I gotta be honest
I think I'm dealing with just a little
bit of a
hangover
this morning
I'm in a bit of a I I have a tinge of
Hangover in my experience it doesn't
take a whole lot of alcohol to put you
in The Hangover State well I can't tell
if it's from alcohol or if it's just
from hockey
um well those are difficult too I think
I have a hockey hangover last night I
went with my my neighborhood friends
this has become quite a thing I see yeah
there's a group of guys dads
who um they discovered that somebody had
never been to a hockey game
this is not uh Lando football flag it is
flag football friends dads yes same
thing same group
okay and um so we went to a what I
caught told Christy this morning was the
Sacramento Kings I was like hold on
that's not right it's the la king she
was like I know who they are they wear
black and I'm like dang you're right
girl well I found it interesting when
you were leaving last night and you said
you were going to a hockey game and I
said the Kings game which I've never
been to and you're like
yeah and I was like how has that slipped
under the radar for 12 years that we've
been in Los Angeles right that they play
at the Staple Center which is now called
the crypto Center so when I said that
this Sacramento Kings played at the
Staples Center it's kind of like
true in a past World kind of a thing
anyway listen to this man
at the end of the game match thing they
told me sorry hockey lovers you know
what I'm just a newbie
be patient with me
um
a dedicated Kings fan in full get up
um there with his son kept leaning over
and like emoting to his
15 year old son about things that were
happening when the whole thing was over
he turned around to us we were like on
the fifth row it was like really gets
really nice seats behind the plexiglass
and um
he said
you know what there's this was a really
great game you guys saw he could tell
that like we were had never been there
before we just that based on what we
were saying through the thing look me
and a couple of other people I think he
picked up on the fact that like we were
coming to grips with professional hockey
for pretty much the first time all you
and all the dads no just me and like one
other dad that was next to me and then
there were a couple I mean one guy's
Canadian so yeah and then blood and then
another guy is a physical therapist he
craps hockey pucks yeah he does he does
all Canadians do right that's why even
they're rabbits [ __ ] hockey pups right
you can see they build a lot of things
out of them too because the way they
stack them so this guy turned around and
he was like this is a really good game a
lot of things happened in this game that
you that you rarely see a fight a lot of
them happened well I mean there was um
towards the end of the game there was
that situation where they're down by two
and they don't have enough time to come
back and I'm talking about the power
play
um they took the they took the keeper
out yeah and they replaced him with
another player so the goal was just left
bare ass open
just I mean it's just like he's like
been over a barrel back there yeah right
uh with your britches but it's so little
that it doesn't really matter
or does it because so all the action was
down here at our end when they were
trying to catch up the king's Kings won
so it was the other team that was trying
to catch up what was the other team the
the white one
you don't know who it was uh
it was Edmonton
that's a Canadian team yeah yeah which
uh anyway
some some one of the one of the key
really paying attention really got the
puck and I'm telling you he was still on
the defensive side of the rink and he
sat there and just like launched it
shoot
and it went right on the goal go that
never happens I'm told
this was after the first fight had
occurred oh
and let me tell you there was a fight
man right there pushing people against
the place of glass there was a dude like
hitting the Plexiglas like people I I
was like is that okay and they were like
well he's being a little obnoxious but
it is okay is that okay and then the
all of a sudden a second fight broke out
like you know 10 minutes later how long
did they let it go on
um first one not too long second one a
little bit longer and it was like right
there in front of us that was amazing
but how committed my experience with
hockey fights is that it's like it was
like they were smiling it's sort of like
yeah we're doing this it's kind of a
routine almost like I'm not actually
trying to really hurt you well the thing
that
um
my Canadian friend explained to me was
he was like yeah that's
um speaks English he speaks English
interesting I was like they measure the
hits like you look at their the
scoreboard and there's the score
which I totally expected
then underneath it there was like hits
they count the hits and display them
this is when it a hit is when you have
the puck and then somebody hits you like
checks you
like they measure that for what well he
said somebody to bet on he said it's a
probably he's he said it was a
measurement of like taking a toll on the
other team
it's just something they'd like to match
Street Fighter hitting each other so
then uh will the physical therapist he
was explaining to me he was like
um there's gonna be another fight I was
like what it's like sneezes it's gonna
be another fight I didn't think they
fought anymore there's always another
one and then that's when the second
fight happened and then when that fight
was over he was like yeah this I I was
like how did you know that was going to
happen he was like well that
I could tell that they were getting real
chippy with each other and I was like I
can infer what that means and then
it it creates like a an energetic shift
in the game so so fighting is actually
used as a technique to
shift the emotional energy like to in
your favor
which I never thought about it yeah yeah
it's like it's like decimating the other
team like if you can it and on the other
side of that second fight yeah I mean
the energy was totally different
another thing talking about energy that
I didn't know about hockey was
he said you know if you look
they are subbing themselves out
every 45 seconds or so like in the
middle of play you'll just see a group
of people jump over and then a group of
people Retreat to the to the bench and
he said because they're going at such an
intensity
that they can only last for like 45
seconds you can relate to that
right is this a sexual joke yeah that
was a sexual joke okay it almost landed
I don't even think you were listening it
landed
he glazed over man uh see I lost
interest this is the point where I need
to punch you to really change the energy
yeah I mean you're talking about yeah
okay so
but yeah they have to they're going at
such an intensity that they gotta that
they gotta rest constantly
because the game is so fast like I much
respect to the hockeyers yeah I'm just
gonna tell you right now it's better
than the soccer it's like soccer but a
little a little too cold
I'm gonna dress warmer next time
but it's fast and it's intense could you
keep up with the puck and then
um kinda and then
I'm like what is that on the uh on the
ice there's like something here there's
something there there's four of these
things and then I look up and two and
lo and behold my friend was right
they some two players had thrown their
gloves to the ground yeah and then they
were they were they had their Dukes up
and they were about four feet from apart
from each other just squared off like
two boxers in a ring yeah and everybody
just started backing away that the ref
could have easily just right there in
the middle of that and said nope
everybody just backed away made a circle
and they were duking and then they just
started like punching each other in the
raw face but but not like not as
aggressively as this
blood dude no no it's not UFC
but there was blood coming out of the
game they'll knock their teeth out yeah
I mean that's crazy three fights I'm
never going back it's never going to be
that good again uh
I'll give you a hundred dollars if you
could tell me what icing is
uh
well I'll let's see I don't want to
spoil it but I'll I'll tell you on your
birthday well that was your opportunity
to say what goes on a cake and then you
would have gotten it easy well that's
kind of what I did Rhett uh get it your
birthday oh that was pretty good see it
was I'm a thinking man comedian I'll
give you a hundred dollars come on man
you gotta hey I'm you are you hungover
come on man I think it must be
contagious slap yourself you know the
interesting thing is that
um I kind of got a I got a little bit of
a uh
uh inside look at this over Christmas
that's what I wasn't even gonna tell
this story but I now that you're telling
it you can't resist
my father-in-law is the official dentist
of the Carolina Hurricanes
and they met they say the fewer teeth
that they have the better player they
are yeah and uh we played poker one
night
uh with him don't tell me you use hockey
teeth in a cut in a in a couple of his
uh dentists and some other guys okay
and one of the dentists was sitting next
to me and was basically saying yeah I
got a
I gotta go in in the morning it like it
was like I go in on Christmas Eve or
something it was going in at a time that
he wasn't planning on going in
because he had to do some because
somebody got their teeth knocked out
and of course he couldn't say who it was
like he couldn't tell us a mixed company
because this is all this is Doctor
patient privilege HIPAA stuff so he
can't like discuss it openly with people
like me
there but he was basically I got to go
in you know there was an accident or
whatever but if I could tell you who it
was you would know him of course you
probably could have watched the game and
and or the match and figured it out but
yeah I mean it happens on such a regular
basis that of course not only is this
like a sponsorship kind of relationship
but uh and and by the way anytime you
want to go to if not if you're a hockey
guy anytime you want to go to a Carolina
Hurricanes game back home they've got a
box because they're the official dentist
of I Want to Be Right Carolina
Hurricanes if I can't slap the
plexiglass oh that's a problem I don't
want to go but you get free food I don't
want to go further away
you know me I'm not big into food I'm
more into Just Hockey like it's all
about the game to me at one point I
started talking to
um my friends about
um
well you know how often how often they
have sex
and my ad during the game yeah my
Canadian friend said this is the type of
thing we should talk about over coffee
yeah yeah
I'm glad they've got I'm glad they're
holding you in line a little bit and not
letting you dictate that conversation
yeah I'm the low man on the totem pole
over there
it's nice because you know here I just I
just riding High I get away with
everything
[Laughter]
um hockey man so they didn't they didn't
they didn't volunteer that information
but if they did you would now tell it to
all of us on a podcast uh if they told
you how often they had I got I got some
good data uh I had a lot of sex over my
break
um I'll talk about that in a moment
um
but first I guess in some sort of
vertical uh
bite-sized form is on is on Snapchat
sounds pretty awesome sounds pretty
awesome to me you know I don't I don't I
don't go on Snapchat we are where you
are if you're on Snapchat then
conveniently you can you can we can be
there with you
here biscus is supported by chime do you
look at your credit score every day not
every day but you know who does chime
does with their secured chime credit
Builder Visa credit card you can start
to build credit with your own money
chime reports your payments to credit
bureaus to help you build credit over
time there are members see an increase
of 30 points on average all of this with
no annual fees no large security
deposits or credit checks needed to
apply this would have been uh helpful to
us right after we graduated college and
because with the state we had left our
apartment in by writing our names in the
bottom of the bathtub with that
scripted grip tape my credit score my
credit score tanked at that point I
don't know what happened to yours man it
wasn't good it took years to build back
up we could have used chime at that time
but it wasn't available so start your
credit Journey with chime sign up takes
only two minutes and doesn't affect your
credit score get started at chime.com
ear that's chime.com ear the time credit
Builder Visa credit card is issued by
stride Bank in a pursuant to a license
from Visa USA chime checking account and
200 qualifying direct deposit required
to apply for the secured chime credit
Builder Visa credit card regular on-time
payment history can have a positive
impact on your credit score impact the
score May Vary and some user scores may
not improve out of network ATM
withdrawal fees May apply except at
money pass ATMs in a 7-Eleven or any
Allpoint or VISA plus Alliance ATM
so your your your break I feel like I
want to hear about your break
okay I can I can uh I can
scratch that itch for you yeah yeah my
break started uh it will summarize it
was a trip to Raleigh
to North Carolina
and then it was home of the hurricane
followed by a trip to Mexico with just
my wife oh yeah oh yeah let's start
though
let me set the scene for you
December 20th
at Los Angeles International Airport
okay we've never flown
on that particular day would usually fly
17th
maybe 18th Jesse's birthday is the 18th
so we typically try not to travel on her
birthday and we are usually in North
Carolina for her birthday
kind of times out most of the time so we
get in there and have like a week before
Christmas
we were like let's have her birthday
here
didn't we do something for her birthday
remember that yeah yeah oh we missed the
last time I saw you we were at a party
bus oh gosh we did we run at a party bus
that's a story in and of itself it's
full of glitter oh my gosh it turns out
oh good yeah man we gotta tell this
story right well I didn't think about
this first of all it wasn't my idea to
do the party bus and also it was it was
Jenny Mike's wife it was her idea to do
a limo because we were talking about
what we're gonna do for Jesse's birthday
and she's like well let's get a limo and
Jesse's like that's a great idea turns
out in 2022 when you request a limo it's
not going to be like the limo that took
us to prom which is like a long Lincoln
it's going to be most likely a party
buddy because it's just got more room
and you can stand up inside no stripper
pulling this one unfortunately but
um it was so anyone stand up well you
can't but I can barely stand up in there
it's kind of a last minute thing but um
great idea
you're um you well your wife had a
little trouble
yeah she I you know she gets car sick
I've told I've told the stories over the
years of like
just the art of pulling over and getting
her out quick enough so that I can start
filming with my phone before she
actually starts wretching into the ditch
like I've gotten really good at that
like yeah pull over Park whip out the
phone
before you post that on Snapchat I post
that on Snapchat yeah that's the only
thing you post on Snapchat but see your
biscus is on Snapchat do you hear that
yeah I heard about that if you want to
watch your biscuits there you can
um
she gets car sick so like
uh she she got carsick pretty quick
right before we left your neighborhood
before he left before and I was like
within one mile we got a ways to go and
then we kind of like roll the driver to
roll the window down
so we could see him and we taught
Christy into asking him can can is it
okay if I sit in the front seat with you
I'm getting car sick he was like
I would love for you to do that but I
don't have another seat
and we quickly put together yeah well
first of all he didn't he didn't
there's the obvious reason for this
because the you don't want a sick woman
the drunk right it doesn't have to be a
woman I mean she is a woman but
you don't want the person who is most
likely to vomit to be up there with the
with the driver no matter what gender
correct right
right in this case it was your wife
though right and also Mike was uh a
little cartoon he was getting car sick
but he just got quiet whereas Christy
kind of like she was in the front and we
were all sitting in the middle in the
back you and I were by this point you
and I were in the back and we were
having our own little conversation you
were showing me something on your phone
and which is a great way to get car sick
which is probably something on Tick Tock
and Christy was up at the front turned
sideways kind of in a vertical fetal
position
like
and I kind of leaned over you I was like
if she vomits I hope she does it down
into like the floorboard so when we open
the sliding door it'll just kind of like
Cascade out this is what I was saying
and you're showing me something on the
phone
and you know and it's all like Poor
Pitiful Christy you know it's like You
Gotta Laugh to Keep from Crying that's
kind of how I felt about it and then she
was having a tough time but then all of
a sudden kind of like you know how in
Lord of the Rings when like Gollum is
talking to himself and it's like Smeagol
versus Gollum and like who's gonna win
and then he he you know he turns his his
um
face away from the camera and then all
of a sudden he turns back and he's like
and it's like oh Gollum wins like
there was the Christie version of that
where like all of a sudden
she whips around
and looks straight at me and you and
she's like
don't you think about putting this video
on ear biscuits
she thought you were filming her
she was jumping to the conclusion that
Not only was I filming but that we were
planning on posting it we would never do
that we would I mean we wouldn't even
talk about it on your biscuits right we
wouldn't do that we wouldn't even do
that we wouldn't recount the story in
detail no
uh but she did make it but it she didn't
make it there she did not vomit but she
she wretched at one point she did a dry
heave oh yeah did you not notice that
the thing I didn't understand is why we
didn't give her something to do it in
because you're talking about doing it on
the floor I don't want just a loose
vomit inside of my party bus
you know what I mean like it's posable
put it yeah but we don't have a hose
right now at the moment yeah I didn't
have a bucket yeah but at least I was
thinking about it a little bit could
have given her like three champagne
glasses
fill these out she's like you could just
it's like a bartender
that we should have given her a
receptacle is all I'm saying yeah poor
girl
uh so it was it was pretty shaped up it
was pretty funny
um trying to trying to just like
how much not partying was happening on
this party bus
but you got to go back to your story
dude
I mean we haven't even gotten your
vacation oh um we were talking about the
airport
I don't know what day you flew but
I'm I just have never been to LAX when
it was so crazy now I show up
as a policy
I'm a typical dad or you know I get
there early
my rule is we get there two hours early
right which is what they kind of tell
you to do but a lot of people are like
oh you hour and a half but I tried to
get there two hours early
well we show up and
it is just a mad house Bedlam and we
have to go to because Shepherd is 14 and
the way that we ended up like putting
the the we were all in the same
reservation but typically you can't just
get a boarding pass for a 14 year old
you have to get into the I need
assistance like I need to talk to an
agent line which is what we always do
yep I don't do the I don't know I so we
get in that line and
I'm like this line is moving very very
slowly and it's very very long and I'm
not that good at math anymore
but it doesn't seem like we're going to
make it and then I ask one of the
representatives of the airline that we
were flying I was like you think we're
going to make it we got a flight to RDU
and she says
uh I don't know I've got to see how
things are shaking out but we recommend
that you get here uh four hours early
for domestic flights and five hours
early for international flights during
this this time of year at LAX
oh God
and I began to panic a little bit and I
this is one I have some certain I'm
going to talk a little bit more about
some things I learned about my own
anxiety over the course of the vacation
but it's well established that I have
anxiety not about the process of flying
but the process of of check getting not
being late not missing the flight yeah
okay and having to introduce like
complications where you have to then get
on the phone with somebody I get I
actually get anxious thinking about it
because I hate having to like figure
logistical things out even though
it's just gonna be me like texting Kara
and having her do it even that is just
you know it's very stressful for me
and so
um and also you know very slight PTSD
from getting stuck in Atlanta Georgia
for three days one day because of a
flight missing a flight
not nothing against Atlanta just wasn't
expecting to have to get all my clothes
from Target
um for three days but the uh
so at that point I panicked a little bit
and I said well I'm gonna go out to the
uh skycap you know check out on the curb
I left the family in line I go out there
and it you know it's a shorter line it
seems to be moving pretty fast
so we get in line there and then we get
up to the guy
he's like everybody here over 18. first
I mean my heart just immediately like
goes to my throat I'm like no he said oh
you can't check yeah you can't check in
here uh
mm-hmm because we were actually on three
different confirmation numbers so you
had to get back in the other line no I
said he I think I'm just gonna I don't
know the guy's name maybe he was an
angel you know how we have experiences
with angels me and you all the time and
I said um
Michael listen we all have the last
thing last name
and uh we're all different confirmation
numbers but we're all in the same family
and he was kind of like okay let me see
what I can do I don't know how this
stuff works I don't know like this is a
policy but I'm about to violate the
policy
and then so he goes to the process and
he's like give me a second I'm I'm gonna
go see if I can figure this out and I
like pulled out a plug you know you tip
these guys that's part of the deal but I
pulled out a 50 Bill I just have to have
a 50. no you didn't I was like thank you
and like as he's leaving to go like
handle I like give it and escort I mean
Hey listen it works wow he came back and
he had Shepherd's boarding pass
we're good to go we made the flight I
just it felt incredible
he may have done it without the tip I
mean I was gonna tip him anyway but I
would more than necessarily going to
give him 50 bucks
um gee I don't know what standard
tipping for the sky cab guy is
I usually throw them a couple of 20s
which I guess is 40 dollars
so maybe I was maybe it was that is that
is forty dollars
um two times twenty is 40. never
forgotten that so anyway my vacation
started with this like elevated heart
rate you know okay A little bit of a
almost crisis now none of my family's
freaking out they don't care that's why
you're freaking out because you have
you're you have to do it well it's up to
you I feel responsible for you you know
you are
um
because that's a gift you give them but
when because when me and you travel
I don't feel that way
like I don't I don't have a lot of
anxiety about like I'm just like if we
miss this flight I mean I'm not as
lackadaisical as you
as you the way that you approach flights
but I'm also like hey if we miss this
flight like we'll get on another one
we'll tell a story about it
but the family is just like especially
around Christmas because you get it I
get it I get it you're worked up
um
it's understandable
now not a whole lot happened in North
Carolina it was a quick trip skip that
man uh I will do one highlight though
oh let's hear that so we're still
um the the cabin
uh that I've spoken of before is not
currently habitable
because my wife is having her way with
it
uh but this will become the place that
we stay when we go to North Carolina
one one year uh down the road
this coming Christmas but uh
I noticed
that some have been eaten my freaking
log cabin
when you you I saw that you posted a
picture of wood but yeah I didn't
realize I didn't put it together that
that was actually that it was a real
that it was a real that was a house that
I was being sincere no I just thought it
was like a wood pile it was just the
corner of a log cabin where the wood
comes together
and you know before we got this thing it
was all like sealed and stuff inside it
was inspected like I knew that there was
not this like raw
wood and you know as I'm not there on a
regular basis and so like you're
checking in and we did we did some work
and and we met some guys out there to do
some work but
I'm looking at this and I'm like I
didn't want to do this because I don't
really like to do the whole like here's
a problem for Twitter to solve because
you know you're going to get like 95
just yeah why don't you do it that way
well what was the other way to do it
Reddit
yeah well Google
can you Google an image
I tried that yeah you can do that I
tried that huh so crowdsourcing uh I saw
that Alex punch gave you a smart ass
response I knew I was gonna get a lot of
smart ass responses and actually it was
sort of like I was like okay I'll be
entertained by the smartass responses
they're teaching not to take it too
seriously but I hopefully will find the
correct response because I was like this
can't be like a beetle or something like
it looks like something was gnawing on
it but like what then I was like is a
you're like a beaver that I don't think
beavers would do this like a beaver
coming from that Creek
you know behind the house and like
coming up there like no beavers they
like cut down trees to put and make a
dam out of I don't know they're trying
to cut down my house and make a dam out
of my house
it'd be a cool thing to document
but one guy responded and said
I am a pest control specialist in North
Carolina and I am 100 certain that it is
squirrels squirrels because this time of
year squirrels are collecting wood for
their nests so they're taking their
little front teeth and they're just kind
of Shaving off like the out the layer
and apparently your house is being eaten
by square apparently you can put
something on the house
like once you like sand it down finish
it you can put something on the house in
those places to keep the squirrels but
it's also because we haven't been there
and squirrel's like nobody's homeless
eat it you know let's eat the home now
that no one's there so we gotta I mean
it's like a cartoon you come back next
time and like half your home is gone
like in kind of like a
in a squirrel organic
shape I don't think they're going to eat
much you know what you need to do man
you know what you need you need some
really
responsible
handy squatters
you just need some people to squat keep
an eye on the place how about just do
the squirrel a mannequin on the front
porch
or a mannequin on the front porch I
think it's a mannequin with a mechanism
what a mechanism a mannequin that looks
like he has like a 22.
yeah just a mannequin with a BB gun
there can be a like
it could raise he could raise the BB gun
and then the little speaker
could could do like a countdown from a
dramatic countdown from 10.
Like Home Alone nine you want me to
Macaulay Culkin my front porch yeah I do
tis this was the season I like this idea
well I don't want to talk about Mexico
I mean I'll hear a little bit about your
trip before I continue on with my trip I
experienced the airport if we have to go
there again uh I don't want to do it on
let's see we picked up my mom on
December
20th I think wasn't it like the day the
day we were leaving you were picking her
up yeah I think maybe it was the 19th
but like
we go to pick her up and she like I said
she calls me when she lands and then I'm
like text her I'm like get your once you
get your bags and come out to the curb
then we'll come up and get you because
you don't want to have to park
you know I I wanted to avoid parking and
then about that time I hit this traffic
and
like we could not get into the airport
and then I couldn't get in touch with my
mom like she was not answering the phone
it had been uh 30 40 50 minutes since we
talked I was like she's definitely
what's happened she's got a North
Carolina only cell phone she's not she's
not in communication and I can't get to
her I don't know where she is and then
we're like driving around and it is
bedlam people trying to get picked up
and
I'm like Christy we just need to start
looking
maybe my mom is out here my mom this is
the first time she's ever traveled alone
and here she is at LAX who knows where
like out of like Out Of Reach
and
I was like she's supposed to be at
Terminal I guess three it was I can't
remember so then at Terminal 2 Christy
looks up and she's like
there she is
and this had been like I've been
worrying for like 45 minutes and then
she like instantly saw her and like get
her in the car and my mom's like
sweating profusely and like talking
about how I've been trying to reach you
I I use this stranger's phone and I got
them to call you too and then all of a
sudden and she was like it was it was
all I could do just not to burst into
tears
my poor mom is trying not to cry the
whole time and I'm realizing that my
phone is the problem you had like
notifications you had like it I don't
it's one of those inexplicable things
where you just need to restart your
phone so it like it says it is connected
but it no longer was something about how
many people that works of LAX I felt so
bad it was my fault not to be critical
if you're playing
um but uh I would have suggested you
with your mother traveling alone for the
first time that maybe the the
uh parking and meeting her inside was
probably worth the headache oh yeah
we were I was willing to navigate at an
airport I was willing to do it yourself
you know what well you know what
we threw her in the deep end and she
swam out and it's good it worked out
everybody's everybody so she wasn't mad
at you no
no that's good uh there's I mean there's
a sweet lady yes sweet lady PTSD but
okay
um so Mom stayed at our house we had a
great time and then we flew back with
her and saw everybody but then like
turns out Chrissy's side of the family
was sick so like we couldn't we ended up
not seeing them and it was only a few
days home
so he's on my side of the family we had
to get we we had a good time
um it was short and sweet we get we get
back home
um and then we just take it easy you
know I didn't go to Mexico or nothing
yeah uh I just took it easy I got in my
uh my pressurized tank my healing tank
trying to like make sure that this bone
is oh you got in the Hyperbaric I got in
the Hyperbaric a lot
taking naps it was like it's like my
little it worked kennel well
um I'm actually going to the doctor in a
few hours to get an x-ray to make sure
that there's Union
well it looks like there's Union I'm no
doctor it still feels a little weird but
um maybe it's just that I need to
I need to get into with that PT I'm
feeling good though I'm feeling good
about it so
not too much to report from my uh my
holiday
beyond that I think
I was just thinking about you in Mexico
just hoping you were having a grand old
time I had a great time so the
the impetus for this
we knew we wanted to do some kind of
trip
and you know as originally planned it
was with our children oh
um
but I was like y'all y'all want to go to
Mexico for a week we were supposed to do
this last year by the way
covid canceled that so I had I was kind
of playing this mental game of not fully
committing to like gotcha simultaneously
being very much like way more looking
forward to being on vacation than I
should have the way that you usually
look forward to a vacation and you think
it's going to solve all your problems
and be this incredible reset but then
the other part of my brain was like it's
probably not going to happen because
somebody's gonna get covered whatever
uh-huh
but when we asked the boys if they
wanted to go it started with lock and he
was like ah you know I'm coming back
from school and I really want to see my
friends in Los Angeles who were like
okay and then Shepard was basically I
don't want to go by myself and nobody
would really have no friends to take
because they're doing their own thing
so I was like okay we'll go by ourselves
we'll we'll sacrifice for you guys just
go on a vacation just the two of us
which means
that lock and Shepherd would be home
alone for a week in Los Angeles by
themselves 18 year old 14 year old who
never
been responsible for a home
and our two dogs yeah
so there were a number of heated uh
interactions leading up to that which
where I there were some things that
happened in the days leading up to just
going to North Carolina
when when lot was already home that kind
of demonstrated and reminded me that
they're just teenagers and they don't
clean up after themselves and they leave
stuff hanging around all this stuff I
was like you can't leave food out to
kill these dogs you know like we have
like very dad conversation with them and
like you got to make sure you can't
leave the door open and then go outside
like basically now it's just kind of
worried about the dogs it's just to be
frank yeah and um
but we eventually got to a place where I
said if the house is clean and the dogs
are alive and we return then I will be
fine okay
and then uh
some friends ended up coming through
town and eating the place to stay and I
was like yes please stay at our home
adults right so they only ended up
having like two days alone
so that ended up being fine and I was
actually thinking it was going to affect
my enjoyment in Mexico because I didn't
want to be thinking about what was going
on in my house and like having to check
in constantly
but this is the longest trip that well I
mean I'm not 100 sure about this but I
think this is the longest
trip that just the two of us have had
since our honeymoon because we just
don't go on vacation just the two of us
I mean we're going like a weekend trip
but we can get away seven days but yeah
seven days
and
a few highlights I mean we were in Playa
del Carmen which is actually where we
went on our honeymoon
and oh but we were kind of like at a
resort that we left just a couple of
times it was definitely like focusing on
the chill aspect of a vacation and
trying to just completely unplug
and enjoy ourselves nice and which came
at a really good time for both of us
Jesse said the busiest year of her
professional life
and so she's been like
you know running like crazy
we had a crazy year as always so it's
the break is always welcome
um
I swam in a Cenote
Cenote three cenotes I've seen pictures
of these it's like like an aerial photo
of a Cenote is this like jungle but then
all of a sudden there's like a donut
hole in a jungle and it's water it's
like a but it's like a so it's like a
pond but not like the it's there's like
it's deeper it's a lot essentially a
cave that that has an opening somewhere
to the surface and it's you know it's
it's in areas that have a lot of
limestone and I don't know exactly what
the process is but any place that
there's a lot of limestone
at one point that was ocean and then
it's like over time it kind of drains
out and reveals this like swiss cheese
essentially like the the Earth becomes
swiss cheese that is filled with water
okay and at some point apparently the
these caves didn't have water in them
and like people could kind of walk
around and then in relatively recent
geological past they have filled up with
water
and they filled up with like pristine
crystal clear water is it it's rain
water or like groundwater or ocean water
salty it flows to the ocean they flow to
the ocean and they are fresh water
they're fresh water oh and the action
and like so we went with uh a guide uh
whose name was limbert
limbert uh who was actually
um with that name you may not he was
local he was local and he's kind of a
archaeologist historian like he gets his
uh
he gets his like license as a as like a
historical guide to this region of
Mexico he like gets it updated every few
years so he's like this dude knew a
whole lot and he's also
I didn't know this
and this is just ignorance on my part
but like
if you had told me like okay uh are
there Mayans still around I would be
like well yeah I'm sure there's like
descendants of Mayans and the Mexican
people or whatever but like
Mayans and and Mexican people are it's
two distinct groups okay and the and the
Mayans they're still like millions of
people who are like of my own Heritage
and speak Mayan like he grew up speaking
mind of course you speak Spanish as well
in English really
um but he was like telling me about and
it's like you know there's Mayans who
are in Mexico and Guatemala and you know
down into Central America
still millions of people and still like
a very intact culture there with their
own language and customs and everything
and so he's like tell me about his
grandmother and and
they have like a real tie to the land
and the cenotes and all this experience
of uh all the history of
what they used them for and you know
he's like clarifying things about like
people think they sacrificed the dead in
these but really what it turns out they
probably did is that they like
had buried people and then they took
their bones and they would put them in
the Cenote like after they were clean I
learned a lot of really cool things huh
this is not a history lesson and I'm
gonna get uh pieces of it wrong
but
we swam in three that day and we swam in
one that was half open half closed
so
like I can't it's like here you go
here's a lake sort of area and then it
goes into a cave that you can swim
through and comes up into another Lake
area and when you swim through it's a
there's enough air you don't have to
hold your breath to go from one to the
next it was there was never a place that
we had to completely
do that well so the second one the
second one which was the crazy one which
was a completely enclosed one that had a
stairwell
I've got pictures of all this that if
you're watching on video you're seeing
right now but we went down these stairs
and they had like built the stairs and
built some things into the bottom of the
thing
that kind of made it feel a little bit
Disney world-ish you know what I mean
like how
far down did you go like what was the
depth of stairs 30 feet to 15 feet oh
okay it's kind of like just underneath
the surface of the of the of the ground
okay and we get now there's there's
hundreds of these I don't know how many
there are like and you can tell pen
Peninsula but it feels like there's
hundreds of them and just on this one
like piece of land that we went down
this dirt road like we're passing all
these signs he says each one of these is
a Cenote that you can swim in so when we
get to this one there's no one there oh
wow
and
he took us around to the back like it's
just beautiful water and they put lights
in the water so people could like go
down there and you give you a snorkel
and you can kind of like swim around
it's like 76 degrees or something so a
little a little cold water but like not
too bad and it's that way all year round
you know
he takes us around to the back and
it starts getting darker and darker and
darker he's got a little flashlight he
turns the flashlight off you can't see
anything and it feels like we're just
like 40 feet into this dark area but we
can't even see the light from where we
came from
and then he's like we're gonna go down
into this little river this little
stream and we're gonna swim in this
stream and swim back around
and I'm not claustrophobic but I was
thinking a uh
my wife is not the most uh what's a nice
way to put this
um
Jesse is Clumsy self-admittedly
clumsy
and I was a little worried about her she
doesn't have a lot of like
she'll step on you you know what I'm
saying like if you're like in a room
with her you know you don't watch her
she'll just step on you okay like
walking past you by accident she'll step
on you she'll she might elbow you in the
middle of the night in bed that kind of
thing
as a big man I've always tried to make
myself small and be conscious of that so
maybe it's just because I'm big and
there's I'm controlling a lot of things
so I I typically don't accidentally hit
people but my little wife hits people
all the time maybe that's how she sees
it's kind of like her version of sonar
speaking of that I mean it's a bat I'm
gonna blow your mind she's a touching
bat I'm gonna blow your mind about bats
as you know I have a
fear of them
we swam around this stick around for
that we swam around this little thing
and he would turn the light on and
he would shine it down into the water
that was like deep like okay we'd be
like going along like crawling along and
like 18 inches of water and then it
would suddenly bottom out and we would
look and it would just be black and
there would be a rope coming up from the
Blackness and he was like that's the
line that the scuba diver's taking it
would go into this cave and they'll swim
to the next Cenote oh so yes totally
scuba the cave to the next thing like an
underwater Trail and with a rope and now
you being scuba certified and me wanting
to be scuba certified but just not
really having logistically lined up the
time to make that happen because
Shepherd I you know I floated the idea
to shepherd He was like a very very cool
thing we call it the four of us could go
together
but going into these caves and seeing
those that was like I want to do that so
he was putting the flashlight under the
water yeah yeah he had like a like it
was like a diving flashlight if I do is
like we can't keep this light on too
long outside of the water because it's
not made for that it gets too hot
diving flashlight you should probably
have one of these uh Chase has one
so I just used his but what I did is I
would dive down
and grab onto the rope and pull myself
for a little bit I went down like 20
feet and did like adjusted my what my
ears and like pulled myself and then I
realized that my lung capacity is just
like dwindled so severely over the past
like 10 years because I haven't been
doing
stuff like that holding my breath yeah
but also I was like oh if you have a
scuba situation you don't have to hold
your breath uh I can't you need to have
another level of certification that I
don't yet for caves for caves yeah you
got to be trained in how to do that but
you'd be willing to you'd do that with
me yeah yes thank you Rhett for the
invitation well I'm just saying some
people are like I'm fine with scuba
diving but they get claustrophobic about
caves I I don't
I'll think about it after I'll think
about it while I'm doing it be like why
didn't I think about this before I did
it yeah that's what I want to do and
because you'll be there you're going to
be in charge you're going to have to be
very in charge no we're gonna go with
somebody who's in charge because I'm not
gonna worry about anything I'm not going
into a cave that somebody who has been
in there many times who is leading us
I'm not gonna I'm not some I'm not
exploring okay I'm not exploring the
caves I'm holding on to a line that
somebody else has put in there whenever
we talk about caves I always go back to
my junior year when I went on a summer
project in Santa Cruz and we
some of our friends from the project met
some like students
at like I guess at UC Santa Cruz and
they took us to some caves these are not
water caves these are just normal caves
I think they've been covered up since
but
and we just had like a little flashlight
not even a headlamp like we were
following we were like on our bellies
crawling through this stuff and it was
so claustrophobic there was one point
where we had to
it's like it got so crunchy like so
crunched down and small like it's like
all right this is a like a four foot
divot that you got to get through this
to get to the other pocket so you and in
order to get through as skinny as I was
I had to empty my lungs yeah I don't
like no I don't like that hold my breath
with my lungs empty and then crawl
through
like that's crazy and hold on if you had
to do that to get through how did anyone
else get through it was a bunch of it
was a bunch of scrawny people there's no
way I would have gotten through it you
didn't know where you would have gotten
through it I don't like that I can't
believe I did that
that's being claustrophobic like I don't
want to be I don't want to be squeezing
through something that's just plum crazy
I don't want to be squeezing through
something where I might get stuck I
don't like that idea where if you decide
to breathe you'll you'll get stuck and
if you gotta and when you've got this
tank on that limits your moveability too
you know yeah but they'll start at one
Cenote and they'll just die and they'll
come up with another one that's cool
I would definitely want to do that we
were going along so
back to Jesse for a moment she's clumsy
we're going along and we kind of get to
this place where we're starting to get
where we can see where we're headed
where the light is in the main cave and
he's like pointing something out and I
just like look at Jesse and she just
sort of just like she kind of stands up
a little bit and then you just
completely just like Falls over like it
just hits a rock with her shoulder
like I don't it was weird like from my
perspective it was as it was as if she
had just like turned off you know what
I'm saying like from the back it was
just like she stood up power down
and she but she had like stepped on
something soft and her foot kind of went
down and so for the rest of the trip she
had this like bruise and like scraped up
shoulder she was fine she didn't like
make a big deal about it when it
happened but I was like baby you gotta
watch yourself
gotta watch yourself and she told me she
told them everything that she was clumsy
and he laughed I was also thinking
uh I don't know how often limbert brings
people into this particular situation
but
uh I can see a lot of people like this
isn't the kind of thing you could bring
like 20 people in their Grandma through
you know what I'm saying like you didn't
uh yeah somebody's gonna get hurt
somebody's gonna hit their head I hit my
head on one of the Stalag
a
types
uh one for top and
I was like hangs tight to the ceiling
t for top yeah that's what I think of
and then stalagmite M for
um
maybe not
don't worry about it if you know tight
then you know the other ones because I I
thought it might be stalagmites fall on
you no that's it's the opposite I
screwed it up for you so
um
but then we get to this point and he
says uh look up and I look up and I see
just a couple of feet away from me
hundreds of sleeping bats a couple of
feet away from you just like you kind of
waited and he shines and it's just like
they're just sleeping everywhere and
there's like like a a bat blanket oh you
hated that what did you do in your brain
uh was what what could I do panic I mean
like you can't get away from them
and I was like did you have a fear
response
even Jesse did because it was like
it's just kind of creepy you know to
like see all these like animals that are
kind of like hanging there are they
gonna fall and aware that were they
fluttering occasionally like a couple of
them would like move a little a little
well they were kind of like a couple of
them would be moving they don't have
wings man they have hands with skin
well that's kind of what wings are wings
are just arms that evolve into but now
with feathers but not with a bad dude
they're still hands with skin yeah
um
when we got back out into the main area
I started realizing they uh that there
was several that were flying around
and that's really the thing that gets me
is a bat that's flying around because of
that time Heather dinklers got one right
on the back of the neck
you know we're outside in North Carolina
and
I I don't know I feel like through
exposure therapy this trip
changed my relationship with bats
because after that I started realizing
that there's bats everywhere in Mexico
uh where we were at including the resort
every single night because there's
there's a Cenote on the resort that we
ended up going to we took a little bike
ride around the nature trail and God
took us in there and showed us all the
baby bats ooh and there were bats flying
everywhere but were they do keying on
you interesting they're constantly
knowing they're constantly guano
is it a verb because it's like probably
not such
they're constantly guanate yeah guanine
into the water
and we asked the question which you were
in so we're in this water and you were
telling me earlier that these this was
the drinking water for the Mayans and he
was like he explained it again details I
don't remember
the guano does not make the water uh not
potable like it's still completely clean
based on the the process that's
happening and the constant like inflow
and it's it's doesn't make never made
them sick it doesn't make anybody sick
and there's literally hundreds if not
thousands of bats in every one of these
caves just constantly guanating into the
water huh
that's not a problem not a problem it's
not a problem it's not a problem Guana
iguana isn't guano is not a problem it's
not a problem
um
okay I'm gonna get to the anxiety in a
moment and I had another uh it's one
it's one of these situations where
something happened that then I
interacted with the internet and now I'm
going back to contextual contextualize
of the situation okay and that was
um I told you about this ahead of time I
told you that I had purchased
um a matching set of
a short sleeve shirt and shorts yeah to
wear on my vacation yeah that's right uh
this is not a first for me uh you might
recall the watermelon set that I had in
Mexico maybe five years or six years ago
that's right uh so this is something
that I am known to partake in while in
Mexico apparently
and while watching season two of White
Lotus
which I gotta say seems to be more and
more recognized as being better in the
second season in the first season just
so you know I mean that's kind of that's
the way the tide seems to be turning
interesting
um
but
what's her name's fling boyfriend from
England in the in the show the quote
nephew the nephew is he he wears this
outfit during the show and I had seen
that outfit advertised to me on
Instagram because that's how Instagram
works it gets into your head and knows
exactly what you like
and ended up purchasing this set but I
went with the pink one
because I was like mix it up a little
bit go pink good
I think I should have gone green there's
green and there's Navy and there's pink
I went pink okay yeah
actually I think the green was sold out
in my size maybe that's what happened
anyway I was trying to figure out when I
was going to wear it
on vacation and since we were spinning
every day man since we were spending a
lot of time at the resort and it was a
nice place but what I was Finding is
that people just kind of show up at the
restaurants in the resort in a they're
not like hey I'm in a matching set you
know what I'm saying like it was it was
more like I've got on shorts and a I got
on mine people weren't dressed up
but it was kind of like I don't know I
got the thing I'm gonna wear it what's
their problem and
um
I wore it
that one night and actually one of the
the couple that was sitting next to us
was like oh he like said the brand the
brand is uh Dandy Del Mar free free ad
for Dandy Del Mar oh yeah not a sponsor
and he's like Danny Del Mar nice this is
Danny Del Mar he was wearing a shirt see
so he was dressed and I and I was like
uh you guys watch White Lotus and she
was like I feel like I'm living it and
um okay and and then
I was like yeah the nephew wears this
this outfit and that I saw it and I was
like I'm gonna get that for the trip or
whatever
but at least we talked about it but then
I like okay we didn't have a converse
much of a conversation with this couple
then we go back to our dinner
and I say to Jesse I said
my outfit is not making me feel like I
thought it would
just a moment of vulnerability with my
lovely wife
and then her immediate response is you
should tweet that she's like that sounds
like a tweet that sounds she was like
that sounds like a relatable tweet and
I'm like I don't want to tweet I want to
see this patient
I saw that but okay go ahead and so that
she was like here I'll take a picture of
you
I'll I'll take a picture of you and
we're in this like restaurant that's
kind of like it have to it's like indoor
outdoor beautiful place uh where like
the canal in the middle of the resort
kind of comes up to where our table was
but there's like people including a
family
of like Mom and Dad and three kids
sitting over there and I'm like I I you
know me I don't
I don't like to be I don't like to stand
up and be like I'm getting my picture
taken in this outfit I don't like to do
that and but Jesse was like just do it I
was like okay this is funny this is for
the internet so I stood up and I kind of
like made a face that was like capture
the idea of I don't feel
it's like this this outfit is not making
me feel like I thought it would yeah I
saw that picture but what I did is I
tweeted it without attaching the picture
and then I replied to the Tweet with the
picture so Jesse you know she's my
social media manager
um that's how you got to do it and uh
she explained why that was the thing
that I needed to do I'm just I just
follow the directions I do what she
tells me to okay and uh
as Jesse was taking the picture of me
standing out there by myself
the mom from the family that was
watching
said
um
if you want me to get a picture of both
of you
just let me I I can get a picture of
both of you
and instead of just saying okay
yeah just say okay please I said uh you
said okay
you don't worry she
um and now more people are listening
other tables are listening because I'm
having to say this to this woman across
across the restaurant oh here's what it
felt like don't worry don't worry she
this is for Twitter uh
yep yeah yeah you made it worse and I
think the upset her you know because I'm
it you know she offered to take a
picture of us and it was like no no this
is just me I want my wife to take a
picture of just me for Twitter
this is a joke like I'm doing a joke for
Twitter you've said plenty yeah to her
um so they must have thought oh it's a
Twitter guy Christy saw this picture
before I did and I'm across the room
petting my doggies and she goes
red just posted a picture of him in an
outfit and I think it's the same one
that you bought
I hate to break it to you but I looked
at the picture and I was like well his
is pink mine is green oh I almost got I
would have gotten the green one if I
didn't have the side if they'd had him I
had my side I
had forgotten because you did tell me
the whole you said I bought this thing
I'm gonna wear it to Mexico you
mentioned that to me because we were
talking about White Lotus I'd forgotten
you said that and then I was like I need
to get some I want to get some
loungewear for whenever I go to Mexico
and
I bought I found myself on the site and
I was because I just searched uh Resort
Wear and then that's the site that came
up yes it's the site for that and I got
to I I was gonna get the blue one but
they didn't have my size so and I wasn't
gonna get the pink one so I got the
green mushroom I got in the pink and let
me tell you man
I
I'm not going to make the mistake you
made
I'm gonna flaunt it hard
I'ma show up to places
and they're gonna be like who is that
well is that when you put these when you
put these things on the internet uh
that's fun now first of all and I'm not
gonna make that face you made in my
pictures I'm putting it on the internet
as a way to entertain of course but as
is always the case whenever you put
anything on the internet people think
you're making what people are searching
for compliments people think that oh
maybe you are here maybe he must be well
here's what I did it's okay if it is uh
well I'm not saying that every picture I
put on the Internet is there I'm there
are pictures of me that I would post on
the internet that I am in some part of
my brain fishing for compliments but
because I have very specifically did not
want that to be the case in this one I
was like you made that face I'm gonna
make this face and I look and I looked
at it and I was like my legs look weird
you know like my knees looks fat or
something like this fans misinterpreted
the face as he needs accomplished some
some people of course some people did
that but then a lot of people uh took it
upon themselves and that's just totally
fine to explain to me why it wasn't
making me feel like I wanted it to feel
and it was that it was it was too close
to my skin tone
I'm too pink to wear pink
yeah which you know uh maybe that maybe
that's the case I I should have got the
green now you've got the green I can't
get the green
um
but I also uh
Maybe
maybe at some point we do go to Mexico
together and we wear that we we wear
pink and the green maybe I get the blue
and the blue and the green
I bought another one and then I wore it
downstairs and Lando and Christy said
you got to return that
from the same site no
from a different site you want to see
this picture
because I've
I've returned it yeah you're making it
you're making a face at me it doesn't
work does it she said I look like a
little
Dutch boy
um like I want to be a Little Dutch boy
I feel like I mean I just feel like
walking around they're kind of kind of
pushing it a little bit the shorts are
are too small but when I looked at the
models their britches were that tight
too
it's all about the look on your face
it's what but and I didn't have the
right look on my face
um
but actually I kind of do have the right
look on my face
you don't look confident enough oh um
okay yeah I don't
um
we had an excellent time did you though
um I'm glad
we had a lot of made a lot of love
uh that was one of the goals you know
you want to make a you want to make love
at least daily so we did that a couple
times twice for seven days that's
impressive dude
I mean at a certain point
you're just like well let's do what else
should we go to you got to mix it up a
little bit I mean skit I mean I wouldn't
have held it against you to skip a day I
would still be like Wowzer
that's good man
well it was a little bit of a goal okay
there you go you know so you actually
you use both set out to
be completionist about it we just talked
a lot about the sex that we were going
to have in Mexico well you don't Build
It Up
two
and so and then we then we fulfilled
that oh wow we delivered on that so but
you were like every single day we're not
going to miss a day
did you have to talk about I think I
said something like that I was like well
we should I mean would you do it every
day and question mark
um
submission accomplished there submission
accomplished yeah we tried a little bit
of that yeah yeah I wore a caller
in my pink outfit
can I borrow the pink outfit nothing is
to be too big for you well maybe that's
what it needs it needs a little drop
shadow it's a double X like that I had
to get a double XL in that shirt okay
that's how small that size runs all
right
um so I uh I noticed something about
myself when I was on vacation and this
is something that's actually always been
present but I it hit me in a way that it
hasn't before maybe it's just because
you know
cumulative years of therapy at this
point make me more sensitive to what I'm
actually feeling and thinking
um good so
I was like we had a really crazy year
last year
you were there
um yeah
but
unlike some previous years where I feel
like there are things on the horizon of
the new year that could be a source of
anxiety for me it felt like a lot of the
sources of anxiety
came to a close we got answers on things
at the end of the year I filled out and
I'm looking forward to have been looking
forward to this year with much more
anticipation than anxiety very excited
about
everything that we're doing in mythical
and the stuff that we're making and the
ideas that we're talking about so it's
more just like a giddy like
maybe there's an impatience of like
wanting to get to it but not an anxiety
about it yeah not even really an anxiety
about is is it going to perform well or
people are going to be into this new
stuff that we're going to try I'm kind
of like I'm not really doing it for that
anymore yeah so
but what I found was
I would find myself
trying to relax into
a book
or just a chair
in having
this anxiety
and then immediately the what I always
have always done is like you feel the
physical anxiety and then you stop and
you try to find the source of the
anxiety in your brain right yeah and
then you're like oh it's that it's that
thing that I'm thinking about it's it's
the kids at home and when something's
gonna happen or it
but then I I started talking to Jesse I
was like you know
I'm beginning to realize that I have
always had a Baseline of anxiety
but I'm always because we've been so
busy for so long
always
able to immediately
um track it to something that I can then
put myself into and I don't have like a
Solve IT dissipated address it yeah and
I'm not like um external
and so and I don't think I don't think I
usually present as an anxious person
maybe to you sometimes or to my or to
Jesse you know more often or whatever
um but I've never been like oh I'm I'm I
have an anxiety problem or I have an
anxiety disorder and I'm not saying that
I do maybe I do I don't know I'm still
exploring this
but what I did what I did find is that
oh no I actually like if you if there
was a dial and there was a baseline of
anxiety I realized that my Baseline is
elevated and it's a physiological thing
that doesn't necessarily have a source
my brain senses that my and I'm not a
psychologist
but the way that it feels is as if my
brain senses that my body is anxious and
then it provides the source of the
anxiety for itself to then try to figure
out and solve and so then I'll do
something like write a bunch of ideas
down or figure this thing out or like
you know come up with something or
execute something and then it dissed my
anxiety dissipates because I've done
something I've identified the source and
then I've gone and tried to do something
to solve it but you're saying that
there's
no that's not the Full Source like at
this point I'm saying that because those
things weren't there I'm saying that
it's not
it's not linked to any particular actual
thing any reality it is a physiological
Baseline that I've been operating at
this
heightened level not like debilitating
but Annoying and sort of obvious present
level of anxiety and it's why I've never
been able to relax on a vacation I
always look at a vacation as an
opportunity to accomplish something like
okay seven days
in Mexico yes you're going to have these
things that you're going to do but
really you're doing this so that a
you'll recharge your battery so that you
can be fully charged at the top of the
year and get all this stuff done or
you're gonna like take in some
information that then you're going to be
able to translate into something that
you're going to accomplish or you're
going to have this moment where your
brain gets silent and then you come up
with this great idea and then you get
back and you tell link about it like
but but I realized two things one the
Baseline of anxiety exists apart from
circumstances so that's the first thing
that I'm and then and then I try to come
up with something to explain the anxiety
and what that causes me to not do is to
actually
acknowledge that oh no you're just
there's there's anxiety there that
doesn't have a source other than just
your disposition and you need to explore
that and not Define some event or
something that you're anticipating but
all but to just acknowledge that oh you
have you have this disposition how can
you go about addressing how can you go
about addressing this Baseline and
change your Baseline which I don't
exactly know yet I'll talk a little bit
about some of the stuff that I'm doing
but but like low level
anxiety is something that is that exists
it seems like that's what you're
describing but because for so long my
remedy to the anxiety has been
identifying the problem then immediately
working towards the solution I'm not
very good at enjoying a vacation
right
and I'm also not very good at
uh and this is an overused term being in
the moment and I've always I've always
known that that I'm not great at being
in the moment but I didn't really
understand what that meant and I don't
fully yet but I'm beginning to think
things like
you are about to go swim in a Cenote
right mm-hmm
swim in this Cenote
uh uh as well as you possibly can like
experience this as fully or only yeah
yeah don't like fully but don't be yeah
like you don't have to nothing else has
to be figured out right now you don't
have to be thinking about anything you
don't have to be thinking about how all
this thing's happening I'm going to talk
about it on your biscuits which is it
has become a factor with a lot of things
now
um but just be like no you're having
this dinner right now you're having this
moment with Jesse right now you're
having this moment with your kid right
now whatever it doesn't have to be on
vacation
and being present for that
um
and just kind of uh
recognizing the pattern and when you so
when I feel the anxiety right now what
I've been doing is just stopping and
doing some box breathing which I know
you're familiar with
but you know it's just I mean you can
look it up but it's essentially
breathing in holding your breath
breathing out holding your breath and
then repeating the process some people I
call it Navy SEAL breathing and that you
you know it and it's actually been
truly transformative in just like the
few weeks that I've been doing really so
I'm just trying to break the pattern of
like when I feel there's this low level
of anxiety chasing it and I would be
like okay well what is that let me
there's there's it's funny it's like
when I turn towards the sources of
anxiety there's like it's like a bunch
of little anxiety guys in a line like
here I'm hey I'm here and if like you
move past him it's like oh I'm here like
there's at any given time and this is
true of I think everybody there's at
least a dozen sources of anxiety there's
a you know the busier we get
the more sources there are but
they're not starting realizing oh
actually it's not about those things
like those things just happen I can
address those things when I need to
address them on the SK at the scheduled
time that I need to address them but
kind of just saying I'm going to put my
hand up to the little anxiety guys lined
up and I'm just going to do something to
address the physiological response that
I'm having so box breathing again it's
not I had to kind of get out of my head
and thinking that I'm going to be able
to address something solve a problem and
then reduce the anxiety and just be like
if there's a pre-existing physiological
thing that's happening in me that's
causing anxiety maybe there is a
existing tool physiological tool in this
box breathing that I can do that
addresses it without having to bring in
a problem to solve and it has been
pretty TR it's been transformative
been doing it quite a bit and then it'll
be like oh you're calm now that worked
now and and then also adding on the and
what are we doing right now can you
enjoy that
and realize that you'll get to all those
little things that are lining up you'll
get to well I want to hear some of that
breathing I want not right now I'm
saying I want to hear you I want to
become aware that you're doing that when
you need it well then I feel like you're
watching me oh I'll be listening
but um I told you that I've been doing
more breathing and then Christy was like
why you keep doing that
what is that she started getting annoyed
by it yeah
well because it sounds like you're
sighing
yeah it's like what's happening to you
over there you're like
are you
disintegrating are you like flopping
flopping over
well
that was that all right that is I'm
gonna Co-op that as my wreck man try
some box breathing yeah it's a good
wreck I didn't have a wreck for this
episode and I knew it was mine boy I've
been anxious this whole episode about
that this has been fun to catch up you
know what mission accomplished
let's close with some box breathing
you breathe in
hold one two three four exhale one two
three four
now hold
what
oh my God it's funny I mean so you do
that you do like six to eight minutes
you want uh I do find that uh I there's
all kinds of uh different versions of
this but one that I found was somebody
that talked about doing a double breath
because one of the things that you're
doing obviously by doing this is like
you're getting more oxygen because maybe
without even noticing it as you've been
you've been breathing shallower and
shallower as you're anxious
but you're kind of like you're getting
more oxygen you're clearing out the
carbon dioxide but a double breath
this is pretty interesting so you when
as you breathe in if you breathe in and
then you realize I can actually breathe
in again
quite a bit more than I just did in like
a second breath on top of your initial
breath
that feels pretty amazing
it hurts
it hurts I'm stretching my lung
oh
all right makes you a little
light-headed but it feels so good
be a part of this conversation hashtag
here biscuits or in the comments on the
YouTube video which now comes out two
days after look at that the audio
version ear biscuits is Monday Wednesday
and of course call us and let us know
how your processing reacting to these
conversations and well you know what we
might just let everybody hear it 1-88
earpod one
[Music]
hi I just wanted to share my experience
with making a list of my top moments of
the year uh it's something uh that was
obviously inspired by y'all your top
moments of the year is pretty much one
of my favorite podcasts they all do
every single year I decided to start
tracking in my phone my favorite things
every single year and it was pretty
awesome and it was really refreshing to
have this list of my favorite days of
the year that I could always kind of
revisit in my phone and anytime I was
going through a dry stretch where it was
maybe a few weeks maybe more than a
month without one of those special days
I would be able to look at just how many
there were in the past and know that
there's plenty more amazing days in the
future so it's a really rewarding
experience and I thank you all for
inspiring me to do that
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]